greetings apiece welcome to the D show D
show you tuning in this week we're going
to talk about teens rebellion solutions
major sign minor signs for example has
your team already changed his or her
name are they more inclined to the
trends of what's cool and fitting in at
the being disrespectful to foul tongue
towards you your mother your father and
many of these other minor signs some of
them that we want to get a grasp on in
the beginning so you can be aware of
these things so now you can nip it in
the bud before it gets bigger and you
got bigger problems with my next guest
was over 35 years experience to talk
about Muslim teens teens in general
rebellion and the solution here on the
Dean show we'll be right back
this is the how you doing say handle our
things that the created heavens on earth
whose blessed us to be here together and
you're the author over twelve book 35
years experience plus and the book
you've written many books one of them
will be discussing today is when teens
Muslim kings Rebell how did you end up
writing a book like this what motivated
you
well actually writing books has a story
when we first came to Canada myself and
we're back in 1973 Hamlet oblong I mean
we're involved with with the community
and Islamic work right when we were
building our first mosque here in Ottawa
and a couple of things happened you know
we attended one all the camps for
children Muslim children and who noticed
that their behavior is completely
unacceptable
and that that really worried us this
going to happen thought we didn't have
children Nathan this is going to have to
happen to our children if we stay in
Canada as this as too much then also we
received an invitation for dinner from
one of the mashallah very committed
Muslims working very hard in building
this new mosque we're building in Canada
and subhanAllah he invited other
brothers and sister who were involved in
the project and with their families and
we saw how the teenagers
behaving and that was an alarming signal
for us this is completely unacceptable
and we started wearing is this going to
happen to us if we steal this country
and that okay for sure they are behaving
this way because of certain reasons what
could be the reasons the straight find
out so start reading in depth about my
my my wife has a background child
psychology also so she's a medical
doctor has a background in psychology so
start read I start building in from the
religious aspect of it in the Serie
so not the problem not grant anything
that have to do with parenting with
raising children and my wife also start
talking about the from the child
psychology point of view and we started
marrying this together and work it very
hard with our children my children to
make sure that in cherubim they are not
going to end up using for language or
challenging their parents if they have a
question we we encourage them to ask no
problem
it has to be played in a nice tone no
rudeness and the hand Robin I think we
did a good job we have four children all
of them are are very active Muslims and
working perhaps they are all parents now
when they are using their children now
so alhamdulillah think it work it very
good and so one of the things we used to
do is whenever we go to any Islamic
gatherings conventions conferences
workshops we take our children with us
and so those others who interact with
them they start asking us what did you
do mashallah they are such nice kids you
know so we do it like you tried out with
but one incident that just hit us and
said that we really have to share our
experience with the rest of the Muslim
community one of our daughters were
graduating from middle school and the
same school must work
children we went to the same school so
the vice-principal during the graduation
ceremony she was called to the stage six
seven times she's the top academic
achiever table stop that
and so the vice-principal during the
refreshment time she approached us and
said a trauma nurse my wife's name tell
me your secret how did you end up having
good children like this I throw a crumb
humbly Siddeley we were just lucky no
she said no you could be lucky one time
true children but four of them you must
have done something right and I advise
you that you share it with your
community so when she said this we're
thinking about you know putting together
something so I can share it with the
community so start thinking now I think
this signal from allah subhanaw taala
that we really have to do something
serious to share our experience with the
community what can we do so start in
doing just for Mom
Akram which we speak to them just for
dads of gathered Amman and speak to them
but that was not enough you know so we
started said okay ma'am you should write
a book and that was back in 1993 when we
started putting together all the
information that was the first book
meeting the challenge of parenting in
the West and Islamic perspective and
hamdullah it was published in 1998
during the ethnic conventions and loser
aunt was the face book on parenting
written by Muslims that tackle the
problems here in North America and soon
enough it all start getting requests
from different people to come and do
workshops for them and we realized that
from these workshops and the question
that we received that teens problem are
was in the mind of most of the parents
that's why I said okay we wrote the
second book Muslim teens two days
tomorrow's hope a practical Islamic
parenting guide and then after this who
wrote blissful marriage then wrote the
other book parenting skills based on
Quran and Sunnah then we're oh I wrote
this this one which was actually a
series of lectures that I did actually
in Chicago and so we were very pleased
with that said why don't people please
put it in a box why I can work for Matt
and I I wrote this one so this is the
story of getting to writing books on
parenting at Hamburg and it's been very
rewarding and and we received lots of
thanks and gratitude from parents who
you know use these books and handling I
mean we make sue to a loss final Tyla
thanking him that were able to be a
contributing part to our Muslim
community in North America and we're
gonna take a break and we got a lot more
we're gonna get into the nitty and
gritty and a lot of the other signs
minor major that you cover in your book
how you can grasp the problem before it
gets even bigger here in the Deen show
with some teens gone rebellion trying to
bring them back we'll be here to cover
all this and more on the deed show don't
go anywhere please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show shake tell us now how
do you stay updated we know doctors and
people in any profession they go for
continuous training to be updated on
some of the new developments but we see
in this development stage of technology
is progressing but morality immoralities
also is increasing immorality morality
is decreasing so how do you stay updated
with the current trends what's new
what's out there so you can
to the teens yeah well actually we one
of the main sources of knowing the
problems of teens is your own children
themselves if you create a very good
rapport and you become an approachable
parent approachability
is very very important in relation with
your team and you allow them to come
back to you with any question and you
discuss with them and you make sense of
what's going on there will be a very
good source of information for you about
what's happening in the teens life of
course also you can for the internet now
and as other books and programs and TV
you can can pick up bits and pieces from
these areas also but I want to get back
to being approachable parent many of us
particularly those who came from an
Eastern background our idea of a good
child that he doesn't ask a question
he's quite he doesn't talk to you it and
as one fact when he talks to you he had
he has to do this it's not he shouldn't
look and I although this is not right
you know this motor was recommended
based on the process LM used to speak to
right there and we will talk back with
him you know so many of the parents
because of this idea which has nothing
to do this lens we do not allow the
children to ask which why are you asking
about this merciful why are asking about
this no don't it is not your business
don't don't ask about this every
question is an opportunity for us
parents to know something what was going
on in the mind of our child every which
is an opportunity for us to help this
child to be in the right on the bootyman
in the right direction so it's very
important that we encourage our children
particular or teens to come back to us
to speak to us about anything in their
life and this wouldn't happen unless we
provide the possibly healthy
family atmosphere akuto the world in the
session with the blissful marriage
unless we may create a very good
relationship with our children so they
feel very comfortable coming back as
being us so if your child come to you
and tell you something that you think it
is wrong he shouldn't have done it
don't throw it away understood how can
we do this and become angry just take a
mental note in your mind and listen to
him it will open up and speaking to you
everything about it and take a mental
note in your mind that there is a
specific problem that you have to deal
with and later be weighted properly see
what are you going to do about it
but never just fund us put him right
here how come you do this you are not
but don't you know the aramis Indonesian
this is not the proper way to to handle
it
keep this channel of communication open
this is the key to having your child
trusting you and listening to you and
thinking after you also be an
approachable parent as for being
approachable parent now we mentioned
some of the signs maybe the the Muslim
identity is being covered by a name
change you cover that in your book also
the disrespectful tongue towards the
parents are these you've mentioned are
these minor and major signs and how do
you how do you work with this now these
are other buying of signs that that you
can detect right away and we can try to
help upsell to get rid of these signs
that have other major of science when
your child starts giving schools when
your child start you feel that he's not
focusing maybe he is on drugs or
something like this when he joins bad
groups and things these are other signs
and all of this happened because of the
environment of the culture and solemn
warning us about environment and he said
it has a huge impact on us in our
behavior in one of us had this Coulomb
eluding in Rodolfo every new boy
is boring and in a state of pure innit
nature and it is his parents the fifth
circle of environment that can change
this nature and we came a room make a
mattress and make him a super reliable
so the environment is very very serious
that's why in our workshops we we give
comparison between the popularity in the
culture and what is the focus there what
are the norms there and what we want
from our children's as Muslims so like
that extreme selfish individuality is
part of the norms of popularity in the
culture what's I called again extreme
selfish individuality oh yes a spectrum
let's let's like physical intelligence
we want instant gratification anything
that that brings and then want happiness
to them we can do without respect to
anything else do you want following
fashion
following the popular group all the time
when we make any decision they don't
think the consequences of their decision
forget about the consequences and this
life let alone the sequencing data
sorry no respect to Authority is not
there you don't respect the appearance
you don't respect their teachers leaders
no so these are norms for the popular
Western teens culture if you look at
what we want to instill in our children
we want them to have family ties and
family values we want them to think
before they make a decision make sure
that this decision is going to piss a
lot of panel data in this life as well
as in hereafter want them to elevate
themselves as you nourish their body the
nourish also their spirit
them to respect their elders parents
teachers Imams
and so on and so forth so certain values
we want to understand our children
family ties and community values so we
want them to think before they make the
decision and the a decision will please
Allah Spano Tyla
and the consequence in this life as well
as in the hereafter are good
consequences
their parents want them to respect their
parents their teachers their demands and
so on and so forth so you can see that
is a big difference between the
popliteus cultural norms and the norms
or the teaching want or cinta and poor
teens are right there stuck between a
rock and hard place as you say because
the property is currents pushing them
from one side and our parents are
pushing to improve ourselves parents
have to understand that they are under
tremendous pressure and try to help them
and each other we can talk more about
how to help them with this peer pressure
we'll be right back with more to cover
this very very important topic which I'm
up here pressure and we come back here
on the Dean show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the deed show so shake tell us
let's assume you're doing everything
right ok it's a whole different story if
you're not even living by the guidance
that's been sent down from the Quran and
the Sunnah and let's say that you're
you're trying your best even with all
the back home cultures you're trying to
eradicate those things but now just
given the environment so you have the
perfect lack that's from the Sunnah and
you're trying to implement this in your
house but now and you're teaching your
children the verbatim Word of God the
Quran and the Sunnah good Allah good
characters manners etiquette all this
but now they go outside of the house and
now peer pressure yes is this just
impossible no it is not impossible
peer pressure it could be positive and
could be negative and that's where the
parents and community role comes usually
the teen is around
with three circles of peer pressure the
first circle is his siblings and his
very close friends this is the fairest
circle around them the second circle is
his classmates and friends and generally
when the Third Circuit is the teens of
the society he may not not know them in
the Whitman individual ways but he knows
what's happening you know what kind of
move is he like to go to you know that
we hang out and the multi you know the
way they behave so his surrounding
surrounded with this three circle of
environment and the first circle has the
most effect on him in terms of peer
pressure so if we succeed in making this
first circle a group of good Muslims
that he can interact with who have the
same interests who can we can help them
and we can apply positive peer pressure
on him and in the same time we can act
as a shelter between him and the two
other sources of negative peer
pressure's coming from the classmates
and from the teens culture in general
and that's where community comes in like
establishing youth centers like the
project you have here the self defense
because stevesie layer from interaction
from activity it is very difficult to
make them sit and give them a lecture
get them involved within an inactivity
do you learn much more can be temps are
very very important so slamet camps
Youth Center selfie defense activities
like the one you have here all these
things will will create this good first
circle of environment for the team to
interact with and to help protecting him
from the negative peer pressure coming
from the other circles I always
encourage all communities to try to
whenever they are building a new center
focus make sure that youth are your
focus in this Center it is much easier
to have like a big humanism
and then at the salaah time you can all
play in the German Asian but if you just
build a mosque as just a mosque and with
that with place for the activity of the
youth you are not really helping solving
the problem so it's very important that
we have youth centers within youth
counselors to understand with use and we
approachable you talk to them help them
make sense out of everything and then
there are other things that parents can
do like take them for spiritual trips to
a lama for example that leaves such
wonderful impression on them and they
meet the reality here they are living in
a cocoon you know yes no bubble and
everything is given no technologies is
right there in the rooms but when you
take them out for for spiritual visits
to some of these sacred places it leaves
such wonderful impact on them also the
the see others how they live coming from
different countries if if you are a few
home country or the country came from is
in the Middle East or in Oran the Far
East go for regular visits there so she
can see the reality of life because here
they are not really they have the sense
of entitlement that everything we can
get there free from their parents and
this is not a right thing to live in
their mind before we leave it's a few
more points for we cut out on this
episode of the Deen show tell us is
there an age now that when a child now
becomes a young adult we call them in
today's society teen that it's natural
to rebel is this just something that
goes to the neck the the natural makeup
is this natural yeah part of it but not
but if you can tame it you can tame it
from every age if you have the right
training have the right approach with
your child you can tame it at early age
and he wouldn't need to rebel but I
think most of the rebellious will be
coming from is that the parents are not
using the right approach they are not
too much restrictive they are not
considering the age of the cell you
don't understand what they are going
through because during this teenage
years there's lots of change
physiologically inside there are
hormones a la sauna sauna is is
preparing this person to move from the
childhood stage to the adult world stage
and they are aspiring for independence
they are aspiring for for to assert
their independence actual not just
independence they are aspiring to make
their own decision yet they are not at
the stage they can fully do this so it
is very important that we try to
understand the psychology and the
physical change that the teen is going
on and and and be very careful because
we become very moody and sensitive
particularly to the comments of their
parents so parents have to be very
careful many times we say things
jokingly to a child but it leaves a very
bad mark on his personality and so I
have to be very careful what kind of
comments are we saying we have to give
them the support needed afterward the
most then good groups you give them
spiritual trips to different places and
and most importantly be an approachable
parent with you feel you can come to
anytime with anything you have in mind
because you will ask these questions to
other if you are not an approach of
balance and you don't know what kind of
answers they are going to get and you
don't want to put your children and this
kind of situation for people who want to
go ahead and reach out you do these free
workshop parenting workshops tell us
about this in the last minute we have
and how people can also learn more about
your work
yes if any community want to have us
coming and do a workshop just send us an
email through the website that will
wlwt's emily dawn comm send an email and
say we want a workshop and also on the
website you will have the different kind
of workshops we do the most important
one is the first one which is very
quizzes for all the others
which is posted parenting skill based on
Quran and Sunnah and that takes a whole
day one day and all we do it for free
handle our blood I mean all what we ask
the community is to pay our
transportation expenses what the man
would put us in a modest hotel when we
Kunti who and inshallah l-'alameen we
will try to give you the tentative dates
we will be available then we can take it
from there in sha allah but we don't
charge any booking fees don't charge any
speaker fees with in honorarium and our
planning we try to do it with cicadas
panatela if you want to do something
give some donation towards a good cause
on our behalf that's all what we're
asking you to do
thank you very much for being with us
may the Creator has earth reward you
thanks and that was our guest author of
when Muslim teens Rebell get the book
get educated get empowered because
through this knowledge and experience of
the experts now inshallah God willing we
can become better parents we can become
better Muslims we can become better
human beings and then we'll get closer
to our ultimate goal Jenna as a family
working and functioning together so we
can produce better results to be better
functioning Muslims in a better society
for a better tomorrow
follow us stay in tune with us on our
Facebook page on our Twitter tune in
every week to the D show we'll see you
next time God willing until that peace
be with you please subscribe to the DCO
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below